si on a ruiné ou en quête avec nous
avait 30 ans vous êtes une figure du
soulèvement de la jeunesse chinoise
vous militez contre l'insécurité et le
racisme dit ordinaire que peut subir la
communauté asiatique en france
expliquez-nous qu'est-ce que quand
qu'est ce que vous entendez par racisme
ordinaire pour compte que tout le monde
comprenne le racisme ordinaire c'est ce
que tu viens de dire que j'ai vécu aussi
quand j'étais gamin on me disait aussi
tu devrais retourner dans ton pays ce
sont des micros agression qui qui ne
sont pas tout seuls
comment dire capable de nous faire
basculer mais la somme de tout c'est de
toutes ces petites phrases de toutes ces
micro agression nous font très mal et
peuvent changer des trajectoires est en
fait en ce qui me concerne il y a des
préjugés des du racisme ordinaire qui
sont parfois positif à premier abord
mais qui nous peine et qui nous dérange
énormément
par exemple on dit que les asiatiques
sont sages sont travailleurs ne cause
pas de problème
en fait je vous dire ça m'emmerde parce
que quand on me dit ça eh ben j'ai
l'impression que je dois faire plaisir
et que je dois me conformer être comme
ça on attend de moi ça ça a l'air de la
période que les chroniqueurs de tpm paix
ne font rien ils sont payés à rien
[ __ ]
même le positif même ce qui paraît comme
positif et ça te dérange c'est ça ça me
dérange
ouais parce que quand on dit que vous
entre guillemets asiatiques ou chinoises
est comme ci comme ça ça veut dire qu'on
en a d'autres qui sont pas comme ça et
donc ça ça m'emmerde
mais ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que en fait on
demande où on veut que les uns et les
autres se comporte d'une certaine
manière et et puis les stéréotypes
peuvent êtres sexués
il ya quelque chose qui me dérange aussi
c'est que il y a une sur sexualisation
des femmes asiatiques et les hommes
c'est asiatiques sont asexué terrain
c'est quelque chose sur lequel je bosse
en ce moment notamment mais auquel sait
des choses auxquelles c'est vrai que
vous nous en parler on dirait qu'on se
dit tous ici sur mes tirs et qu'il a
raison on ya même pas on n'y pense même
pas et c'est peut-être ça qui dérange
aussi bas oui
juger on n'y pense pas dominique serieys
force de l'évidence c'est ça le juger il
et c'est comme ça et ça se discute pas
par exemple c'est comme ça les noirs
sont souriant c'est des choses comme ça
très commune qu'on a tous plus ou moins
dans la tête et qu'on ne réfléchit pas
toujours et c'est bien d'en être
conscient justement ce que ça peut être
extrêmement blessant alors que j'étais
au bon vieux rideaux ça d'ailleurs ne
tous ces préjugés et de toutes ces cases